Hello, my name is Angel Ermanlee, and
I'm a software engineer at Duolingo. I
work on security for the Duolingo
English Test. Today's talk is the human
in your loop isn't thinking. Build AI
systems for discernment, not approval.
So, let's get started with some
background. What is human-in-the-loop
AI? Human-in-the-loop AI is a framework
where a system or process is actively
involving a human
who's participating in the operation,
supervision, or decision-making for an
automated system.
Humans are involved because they're able
to ensure the accuracy, safety, or
ethical decision-making for that system.
They are a piece of that decision-making
where
AI normally falls short. You can kind of
think of this as a linear process where
a model provides some sort of output,
and a human sees that and makes a
decision.
Now, in the age of AI, trust is a big
part of the conversation. Recently, as
technology has developed, a lot of
things that used to be manual cognitive
tasks are now part of technology. So, no
one really memorizes phone numbers
anymore. They're just sitting in our
contact list on our smartphones. When
you're driving over somewhere, you just
put the directions into your GPS, and
you don't really think about the details
of that route. Instead, you just trust
the GPS to come up with the optimal way
for you.
When you're searching something in the
search engine, you used to look at the
top results, and now, as AI is becoming
more increasingly integrated into our
day-to-day life, you might be seeing
some AI summaries at the top instead.
Here's an example of Googling
COVID-19 symptoms, and you see that
Gemini summary at the top. And instead
of looking at the CDC website or the WHO
website, you might actually look to that
as your final answer to the question
that you were asking to the search
engine.
And as these pieces of AI are becoming
more integrated into your day-to-day
life in these atomic little things like
searching for an answer or getting a
result from an app,
your trust of AI systems will increase
and caution will decrease. And this is
something that's happening across all of
society.
A study at Wharton was looking exactly
that. How is AI reshaping human
reasoning and what does it mean for us
as we continue to use it day-to-day?
They've observed an interesting
phenomenon called cognitive surrender.
When a human foregoes deliberation and
adopts AI output as their own with
minimal scrutiny.
They saw this in a study where humans
were asked to look at reasoning exams
and they were given AI resources to
answer those questions.
They realized that AI can either
supplement or supplant a human's
thinking and the human might not even
know it's happening.
For example, for questions where the AI
was right, the human performance
increased by 25 percentage points.
Whereas when the AI was wrong, it
decreased by 15.
This suggests that the humans were
taking in that AI cognition and not
really thinking critically about what
that answer is and instead using those
answers as part of their own
reasoning
together with their human instinct and
deliberate reasoning amplifying those
results.
Most interestingly, they saw that 80% of
participants were accepting those AI
answers even when they were wrong. So,
they were lowering that barrier to entry
and just trusting the AI
even if they weren't really critically
examining the correctness of that
result.
So, at the Duolingo English Test, we
wanted to look at the same thing and we
published some research titled When
Machines Mislead. It was a case study on
the English exam, specifically in AI
human interaction.
So, for context, what is the DET? The
DET is a high-stakes exam for that
measures your English proficiency and
it's fully online and remotely
proctored. You can take it on your own
machine in the comfort of your home and
it still provides high-quality results
that 6,000 programs worldwide are
trusting day-to-day.
As you can imagine with a fully online
assessment, there are some interesting
things that from a technological
standpoint that have to happen to ensure
good quality security. This includes
identity verification, a lockdown
testing environment, as well as a
variety of ways in which AI assisted
monitoring is happening to predict
different types of cheating.
Lastly, we have a final
round of
scrutiny where we have human proctors
review all of the video footage of the
exam as well as all of those AI results.
Specifically for the study, we wanted to
target one of our AI
cheating detection detection systems,
which is copy typing. Copy typing is a
form of cheating where you're writing
down
uh information that you're reading
currently and supposed to something that
you're thinking right now at this
moment.
So, as you can imagine, your typing
patterns differ when you're transcribing
versus composing. And this is something
that our custom model is measuring. It's
looking at anomalies in keystroke
patterns and it's flagging them for uh
sessions that are unusual. So, our model
is highly conservative and so we're
prioritizing fairness for our test
takers. Uh so, this is not a very common
flag. However, when humans are human
proctors are taking a look at these,
they're well trained to
um properly examine those segments and
see if this is a flag.
So, for experiments, we wanted to answer
the question, would a skilled reviewer
catch a false alarm or would they just
rubber stamp it?
So, we know that our proctors are highly
accurate at detecting various forms of
cheating.
We wanted to see specifically if we give
them a fake signal, how well would they
be able to discern that this is totally
legit session.
The way we did that is by selecting
sessions that had no cheating
whatsoever. They were totally okay, and
we made it look like they have this AI
signal that says, "Hey, check if there's
copy typing behaviors present at a
specific moment." We presented them to
the proctors as part of their normal
workflow.
They thought it was just another session
that they were taking a look at. Um and
this did not impact our test takers in
any way.
Their results were quite interesting.
So, we found that despite the fact that
our human reviewers are consistently
scoring above 90% on their accuracy
calibration metrics, they actually
accepted 50% of these fake signals,
meaning they were falsely accusing
people of cheating half half the time.
And this coin flip rate is something
that is a strong suggestion of
automation bias. This means that they're
deferring their judgment to AI
uh without giving a second thought to
whether or not that there's evidence to
corroborate this and if this is a true
uh cheating session.
Uh again to reiterate, these were not
sessions that were actually going to our
test takers. These were historical
sessions, so there was no impact to our
customers. However, this is something
that was definitely very alarming to the
team because in a high-stakes exam where
these results are going to influence
college admissions and visa decisions,
this is not something that we can take
uh
we can just accept.
We knew that the problem was not the
model.
Our model has a 1% false positive rate,
and also these were sessions that were
negatively predicted. We knew that our
problem was not the people. Our people
are highly skilled and very experienced
with detecting cheating. So, we wanted
to take a look at the interface, and
that's where we targeted our solution.
So, we decided to take a look a look at
the human-AI interaction loop.
Specifically, our proctors are given a
series of guidelines about how to
interact with the system that they have.
And we wanted to just update that
proctoring guideline to emphasize two
things. First, the AI signal is just a
preliminary alert. They're the final
decision-maker. And second, when they're
making that decision, they must find
independent evidence in the video
footage before upholding a flag.
This simple copy change led a 21%
increase in rejection rates, meaning
that from 50% only half of sessions that
were rejected
uh the majority 71 were now determined
to be totally okay.
And this is really good because it is
more closely matching
sessions in production.
And for an engineer, this means that we
didn't have to tweak the model and we
didn't have to tweak uh the UI in some
way. We simply had to take a look at the
copy change and this really changed the
way that people were interfacing with
that AI result.
So, what are the implications of this?
As an AI engineer, your interaction loop
determines how effective your AI system
is and also what you can learn from it.
The way that you measure efficacy and
the way that you can uh and the data
that you collect from that to then drive
your next iteration are really
important.
Earlier we talked about the
uh human in the human in the loop AI as
a linear interaction where a model goes
to a human goes to a decision. However,
in reality
that process isn't linear, it's
cyclical.
Models
provide some sort of output that goes
into an interaction that goes into a
human behavior which yields data for
your evals and then later on your model.
You can't really change the way a human
behaves unless you are that human. But,
what you can do is tweak that
interaction such that it can elicit
different results from that human
behavior. And that data is golden. It
leads to better analytics, model
improvements, and future iterations,
including the next generation of your
model, or maybe some different product.
Now, zeroing in on that interaction
portion, we can look at how to evaluate
your system. Ask yourself a question,
"How can I measure and improve the
efficacy of my AI system?"
Looking at structured interactions that
were designed intentionally, you can see
that those interactions yield good data
that are labeled signals that can then
become training data and evals for a
better model. And that is a flywheel
that compounds. As you have the better
model, you can have better data that
then has better interactions with your
human, which then continues to cycle.
Think of your structured interactions as
a system property that specifically
yields high-quality data. That
high-quality data is unlocking
meaningful insights and quicker
development iterations. You're not going
to be spending
days cleaning your data or trying to
find useful insights. Instead, you're
going to have structured data that is
directly impacting your next iteration.
And this is a compounding effect. Uh and
it's cyclical. If you are not being
intentional with that design, you can
get stuck in a vicious cycle where your
model is making confident calls, and
because your interface is not actually
uh eliciting that deliberation from a
human, they just end up rubber stamping
it. And that positive signal is logged
as truth. So, over time, your model
becomes more confident, and the human is
not encouraged to think further. So,
they continue to defer to the AI, and
the AI becomes the person in the driving
seat.
Uh instead, what you want is a virtuous
cycle.
Uh, if you have an interface that forces
independent judgment, uh, this allows
the human to really think critically
about the decisions they're making and
have real disagreements surface. That
means that you have true positive and
negative labels that are honest and get
logged to then continue to have model
improvements that are targeting exactly
where the model goes wrong.
So, let's take a look at some examples.
For example, we have other cheating
flags that are driven by AI. As an
example, we have headphone detection. On
the left, you can see,
uh, a bad pattern that we had where we
were saying, "Hey, the model detected
headphones at this moment. Can you flag
it here?" And it was just asking a
simple yes or no question. We realized
that there's actually two questions
hidden in this single, uh,
single CTA.
Uh, one, we're asking headphones were
detected. Is that true or false?
Uh, did the model correctly predict that
at this video segment there are some set
of pixels that look like headphones?
And secondly, are we applying a flag
that this person had a violation for it
not correctly using headphones at this
moment?
Why is this important? For example, if
there's somebody who has a hearing aid,
that means that the model correctly
predicted that there are headphones or
earbuds detected. Uh, that is a true
signal.
However, we don't actually want to
penalize this person for wearing, uh,
hearing aids. So, we don't want to flag
them for a violation. Previously, as to
not falsely accuse somebody of cheating,
we would select no, but that would be a
bad signal to give to our model. So,
breaking this up into two pieces is
really important because we actually get
more data and it's better quality and
we're not harming the model in the long
run.
Another example is a quality tutor. On
the left here, you see a pattern where
the interaction is overwhelming and on
the right delightful.
So, this is an example of me talking to
an LLM. I asked it to act as a writing
tutor and provide feedback for a passage
that I wrote. The passage was
specifically written as if it was a
English language learner, so it had a
few mistakes or awkward sentences.
It was a relatively brief paragraph and
instead
this LLM decided to give me 400 lines of
text and
it was very overwhelming and hard to
parse. First, it decided to praise me,
then give some sort of feedback and then
completely rewrite my passage even
though I never asked it to.
The feedback was not direct. It was hard
to tie feedback to specific parts of the
input and it was so large that it would
be difficult to actually improve your
writing through this sort of
interaction.
And most importantly, this did not feel
natural. If you were to send an email to
your friend saying, "Hey, can you take a
look at this thing that I wrote?" you
would not expect them to send you an
essay double the length telling you all
the things that you did right and wrong
and I'll also give you a whole new
version.
Instead, you would probably want it to
look something like this.
Here you have a screenshot of a Duolingo
style writing tutor where the text is
directly marked up. The green is
signifying that this is something that
was good and also providing some sort of
feedback when you hover over it. Yellow
signifying something is awkward or a
little bit off and red being direct
mistakes. When you hover over all of
these markups, you can get direct
actionable feedback that's concise and
you can accept the suggestions in line.
Most importantly,
all the feedback is directly tied to a
portion of text.
This is more closely mimicking human
behavior.
Specifically, like in an academic
setting, if you're handing your essay to
a classmate, you would expect feedback
in line as they mark up your text rather
than an essay back.
This is useful because over time, if you
get these sorts of feedback
[clears throat]
points, you can improve
in incremental steps in your writing.
And this is really important for
surfacing the exact same AI output.
Lastly, and probably most applicably to
an engineering audience, is a coding
agent. Now, there are a lot of coding
coding agents out there, and there's a
lot of different UIs, people have their
personal preferences, but I've seen that
there's two patterns that a lot of out
of the box coding agents are falling
into. So, one pattern is that if you ask
it to do something, it's going to touch
a lot of files and give you a giant
diff, basically doing the thing that you
requested all in one go.
This leads you probably to approve all
the changes and then take a look at them
maybe on GitHub,
so that you can see all the things that
it did.
Another approach is that it will ping
you a notification every single time
it's changing some sort of file or
function, and you have to keep clicking
yes, yes, yes, just so that you can get
to the result.
Either way, in both of these cases,
you're just becoming a rubber stamp.
You're accepting all of the changes, and
then you're taking a look at them all in
one go and debugging later. Anything
that went wrong is your responsibility
to then identify, fix, re-prompt, or do
manually.
And
it's not a very delightful experience.
Instead, you probably want a coding
agent that acts like a junior developer.
You wouldn't want a junior developer to
come onto your team and just be like,
"Oh, sure, I can do that." and disappear
for a day and then give you a thousand
line PR. You also probably don't want a
junior dev who's asking you a question
every five minutes at your desk.
Instead, you want someone who's able to
plan, ask good questions, and document
those design decisions, giving you a
good spec and breaking up their PRs in
meaningful and reviewable ways.
This means that it's delightful for you
as a mentor or in this case
developer who's partnering with a coding
agent to experience things in a way that
is easily reviewable. You can highlight
assumptions and maybe answer questions
about them and you can easily see
a plan and the things that the decisions
that it's making before things go wrong.
Also, the steps are manageable and
you're not being pinged too many times.
And then going a little bit into the
data of side of this, if you have
agentic
coder and it's leading an interaction
where a developer is encouraged to just
quickly skim everything and not really
discern.
This means that you're just collecting
these binary signals of accepted and
rejected, usually skewing towards
accepted, and that doesn't really give
you that much information because it's
just on some coding block.
Instead, if an agent is acting as a
partner with a developer steering, you
can get rich data because it's
structured specifically around different
parts of the development cycle and it's
capturing nuanced structured decisions
about the different parts of
the tasks that it's doing. For example,
it can look at assumptions that were
bad, the tradeoffs that it made,
stylistic preferences and approaches
that the developer's taking. And all of
those pieces of data can then continue
to make your experience as a like as
your AI system coding system better.
So, let's look at some design
principles. First, you can engineer the
reasoning. Think about what reasoning
pattern do you want to elicit from a
human and how does your interface
challenge that? So, if you have a system
that is specifically optimizing for
independent judgment, reframe your
system to think of the human as
investigator, not just a validator.
Don't just give a hey, is this looking
good, but instead have it be a more
thoughtful engaged effort.
Surfacing assumptions is something
that's very valuable when you care about
a lot about the quality
of a long-running task. If the model is
stating them earlier on and asking for a
sign-off, you can prevent any future
miscommunication or having to go back
and fix your assumptions.
Weighing trade-offs is also very
important because very often
an LLM might give you some sort of
option and it thinks it's best without
having to actually weigh the different
different
trade-offs and design decisions that
it's making in the background.
Presenting those options and the
reasoning for why allows the user to
continue to be in control over the
output and they can opine earlier on so
that they can get the thing that they
actually want. Lastly, for sustained
attention, you want to build in friction
exactly where the stakes are high. If
you want the person to slow down and
think deliberately, friction is your
friend, which leads us to the next
principle to match the friction to the
stakes.
In a high-stakes example like ours where
the Duolingo English Test really matters
for people and their livelihood, we want
our human reviewers to be deliberately
slow and very thoughtful with the
decisions that they make. This means
that we want to be adding review gates
that are well-structured and friction so
they can slow down and think about these
things so that they can never become a
rubber stamp.
You [snorts] want these people the
people to slow down
and you want the output to remain high
quality. You don't want noise and you
want clarity. So, this means that you
have to be actively thinking about what
friction
like what speed bumps you want to put
along the road and how and what
checkpoints.
For systems where you have low
oversight, for example, something
delightful where you're just chatting
with an AI, you want to make sure that
it's relatively frictionless. Your
design has to optimize for a happy
someone who's happy with that output and
doesn't really feel like there's a lot
of
stopping points or scenarios where it's
kind of difficult to interact with the
system. Instead, you want it to be
absolutely seamless.
Next principle is every interaction is
already a label.
Instead of having to select a portion of
your data and have human annotators
get you a better cleaner data set, you
can kind of already start thinking about
that specific interaction piece as
already providing you labels and signals
for your next iteration. So, if the
agent plan was approved or a suggestion
was accepted, this means that you did
something right and your output matched
the intent of the user. However, if the
output was modified or in a
recommendation was overridden, that
probably signifies something bad.
However, a lot of systems don't really
capture that diff and the model falls
short because what you get on that
decision is a yes or no. And the human
clicked yes, then manually went in and
changed something or erased it
completely.
If you don't capture that diff, which
could be something for the
the AI falling short or maybe completely
being wrong, you actually capture a
false signal that then can pollute your
data sets. Instead, think about how can
you measure that diff?
Lastly, there are also questions that a
human might be asking. For example,
explanations or follow-ups. And this
could mean that the human has a low
trust in the system or there was
something wrong with the AI.
Uh so, take a look at the kind of
questions that are being asked and what
sentiment they have.
Another principle is to stop asking how
to evaluate the model.
Instead of building your system and then
being like, "Hey, what kind of data can
I capture to see if this is good?"
Proactively think about what defines
success for your AI system. Think about
how you can be measuring that with
concrete metrics and what data will you
need to improve the system from the
start.
Those decisions will be informing the
way you design that interaction such
that you can ensure that you have the
hard evidence for that next step. Every
interaction should be helping the user
to teach them how to improve the system
and be a partner with the AI.
This leads me to my final point, which
is all of those things are leading you
to engineer that interaction. There are
different ways to engineer that
interaction, which I've covered briefly,
but some of the principles are this.
First, you can have structured inputs
and outputs. That way you don't just
have vibes or giant walls of text.
Instead, you have specifics. You can
think of this in terms of forms that the
user is filling out, structured output
in forms of tables, markup UIs, for
example, that
writing tutor or maybe it's a design
thing where you can highlight specific
elements. All of those ways are having
targeted interactions between the human
and the AI ensuring a better result.
Next, highlighting that those
assumptions. If you are having
assumptions being made by the model, if
you surface them proactively and ask if
it's legit, that's going to save you
some tokens down the line so that the
human is not having to fix or argue or
correct with the correct the model
output. Instead, it's being proactive
and the having those things that are
core
pieces of information that are going to
inform later decisions.
Next is building in friction and review
gates. That deliberate slowing down so
that you can have good quality thought
and just required for good quality
decision-making and good quality data is
all important because if you're bringing
in that friction and review gates,
people are going to start thinking
clearly as if it's really their own
thing rather than just something that AI
is
supplanting.
Lastly, collecting explicit feedback is
really important because as we've
covered, every one of those interactions
is a piece of data. So, all of those
signals are going into your next
generation of the model, and collecting
explicit feedback, not just a thumbs up,
thumbs down, but instead feedback at the
correct touch points,
uh with the correct amount of nuance is
something that can really drive
improvements directly.
So, yes,
uh you should be designing for
discernment. Sometimes the fix is not a
better model or more oversight, it's
just engineering the interaction itself.
Thank you.